Hi everyone. It's Caitlin Luna, host of Speaking of Psychology. This episode was recorded live during APA 2019, our annual convention that was held in Chicago this year. I was away on maternity leave during that time, so my colleague Dr. Vale Wright was a guest host. We hope you enjoy the episode. Hello, and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a podcast by the American Psychological Association. I'm Dr. Vale Wright, the director of research and special projects at APA, and I'm guest hosting this podcast today coming to you from APA 2019 in Chicago. Joining us today is Dr. Cresselis Wright.
大家好。我是《心理学谈话》的主持人凯特琳·卢纳。本期节目是在美国心理学会（APA）2019年年会上现场录制的，今年的年会是在芝加哥举办的。当时我正在休产假，所以由我的同事瓦尔·赖特博士担任客座主持人。希望大家喜欢这期节目。你好，欢迎收听美国心理学会出品的播客《心理学谈话》。我是瓦尔·赖特博士，美国心理学会研究与特别项目主任，今天我从芝加哥的APA 2019年会现场为大家主持这期播客。今天做客我们节目的是克雷塞利斯·赖特博士。
She is the director of media and migration lab at the University of Central Florida, and we're going to be talking about fake news. I mean, my goodness, fake news. It's 2017's Word of the Year. It just made it into the Oxford English Dictionary, and it's everywhere. So I'm hoping we can really talk about and have a dialogue about what does it mean when intentionally fabricated content is spread as fact, and why should we care about it?
她是中佛罗里达大学媒体与移民实验室的主任，我们将讨论“假新闻”。我的天哪，假新闻。它是2017年的年度词汇。它刚刚被收录进《牛津英语词典》，而且无处不在。所以我希望我们能真正讨论并对话一下：当蓄意捏造的内容被当作事实传播时，这意味着什么？我们为什么要关心它？
So that's what we're going to talk about today. So thank you for joining us. Thank you for having me. Absolutely. I thought maybe one of the ways to start would be, if you could tell a little bit about your background and how you kind of came to studying this type of thing, because I don't think a lot of psychologists necessarily go into this.
这就是我们今天要讨论的内容。感谢您的参与。谢谢邀请。当然。我想也许我们可以从了解您的背景以及您是如何开始研究这类课题的开始，因为我觉得并不是很多心理学家会涉足这个领域。
Well, my doctorate degree is in developmental psychology, and I'm in the psychology department at the University of Central Florida, and the majority of my research up until, I don't know, a couple years ago, focused on the influence of music. So most of my research focuses on the impact of like entertainment media and other types of media on consumers. And I started to become interested in fake news because of things I started seeing in 2015, 2016. It seemed like that term started to be thrown around a lot. Everyone was accusing everyone else of presenting information. and everything was called fake news,
我的博士学位是发展心理学，我在中佛罗里达大学心理学系任职。直到几年前，我的大部分研究都集中在音乐的影响上。所以我的大部分研究关注的是娱乐媒体和其他类型的媒体对消费者的影响。我开始对假新闻产生兴趣是因为我在2015年、2016年看到的一些现象。那个词似乎开始被频繁使用。每个人都在指责对方在提供信息，所有东西都被称为假新闻。
but alongside that, I started to, I think we all started to see an increase in very overt prejudicial behavior that was presented to consumers through various media avenues, and I wanted to know why that was happening. So that's why I started looking at fake news. And we're all kind of consumers, right?
但与此同时，我想我们都开始看到，通过各种媒体渠道呈现给消费者的、非常明显的偏见行为有所增加，我想知道为什么会发生这种情况。这就是我开始研究假新闻的原因。我们大家某种程度上都是消费者，对吧？
Yes, yes. I'm including myself. Right, but we're all consumers. Of sort of what's going on. So when we're thinking about the fact that we're all consumers, our family, our consumers, you know, how do we explain what is fake news? Why is it a problem? Well, there's, it's kind of hard to define
是的，是的。包括我自己。没错，但我们都是消费者。关于正在发生的事情。所以当我们考虑到我们都是消费者，我们的家人也是消费者时，你知道，我们该如何解释什么是假新闻？为什么它是个问题？嗯，这有点难定义。
because everyone is using the term, but the way I use it or define it in terms of a research perspective might be a little bit different. So when I'm looking at fake news in terms of research, I'm looking at false, completely false information that kind of perpetrates rumors, spreads misinformation with the intent,
因为每个人都在使用这个词，但我从研究角度使用或定义的定义方式可能略有不同。所以当我从研究角度审视假新闻时，我关注的是虚假的、完全错误的信息，这些信息助长了谣言，传播了错误信息，其目的是……
of providing false information to consumers, which is different than, say, a news report that's presented from a biased perspective. Sure. And so where does satire come into this? Because I came across this website the other day called Taiters Gonna Tate. Oh, I actually was going to talk about that today.
向消费者提供虚假信息，这与那种从偏见角度呈现的新闻报道是不同的。当然。那么讽刺作品在其中扮演什么角色呢？因为我前几天偶然发现了一个叫“Taters Gonna Tate”的网站。哦，我今天正想谈谈这个。
Well, excellent. So, I mean, where do you fit that in? I mean, it's a satirical website with very provocative, provocative headlines that are meant to be provocative. And it says all over there's these disclaimers where satire, We're satire.
太好了。那么，您把这个放在哪里呢？我的意思是，这是一个讽刺网站，标题非常挑衅，旨在引起争议。而且到处都有免责声明，说我们是讽刺，我们是讽刺。
Well, see, that's a problem. Not everyone reads the disclaimer. I mean, you know this. Not everyone reads the fine print, right? Like, usually we just, for instance, if you go to download an app on your phone and you have to agree to the terms and conditions, we don't actually read that. We just hit the box and say whatever and go straight to it. So we don't read the fine print, but consumers aren't provided with the tools necessary
嗯，看，这就是问题所在。并不是每个人都会读免责声明。我的意思是，你知道这一点。并不是每个人都会读细则，对吧？比如，通常我们只是，举个例子，如果你在手机上下载一个应用程序，你必须同意条款和条件，我们实际上并不会去读。我们只是勾选方框，说随便吧，然后直接跳过。所以我们不读细则，但消费者并没有被提供必要的工具……
to be able to decipher satire versus actual fake news. And we saw a recent example of how misinterpreting information, how it can actually influence attitudes and even behaviors. So recently there was an instance that involved two police officers in Louisiana, which might be how you came across the website. Taters going to Tate in the first place. So we had a situation where there was a police officer who was on social media, I believe he was on Facebook, and he saw a post that I believe he believed it was true. And the post talked about how one of our Congresswomen, it said something to the effect that she believed our military were overpaid for their services. And so he read this article or whatever the information was on Facebook, felt really strongly about it, and then posted a comment that was interpreted rightly as a death threat against the Congresswoman. And then another police officer liked his post.
来辨别讽刺作品和真正的假新闻。我们最近看到了一个例子，说明误解信息如何实际上影响态度甚至行为。最近发生了一起涉及路易斯安那州两名警察的事件，这可能就是你最初发现“Taters Gonna Tate”网站的方式。当时的情况是，有一名警察在社交媒体上，我相信是在Facebook上，他看到了一篇帖子，我相信他认为那是真的。帖子谈到我们的一位女国会议员，大意是说她认为我们的军人薪酬过高。于是他读了这篇文章或Facebook上的信息，对此感到非常强烈，然后发表了一条评论，被正确地解读为针对该女国会议员的死亡威胁。然后另一名警察给他的帖子点了赞。
Both of the police officers were fired, especially because of the post that the death threat was a bit much, and that's why they were fired from the force. But the post they were responding to was from Tater's going to Tate? That's the name of the website. But they have a social media account and they posted this post. It was intended to be satire, but obviously when they read it, they didn't understand that it was satire, believed it was factual. information and it led to, you know, strong emotions, feeling upset, which led to the posting. And, you know, we know that, you know, those types of things can lead to our changing our attitudes.
两名警察都被解雇了，特别是考虑到那条死亡威胁的帖子太过分了，这就是他们被警队解雇的原因。但他们回应的那篇帖子来自“Taters Gonna Tate”？那是网站的名字。但他们有一个社交媒体账号，他们发布了那条帖子。它本意是讽刺，但显然当他们阅读时，他们并不理解那是讽刺，认为那是事实信息，这导致了强烈的情绪，感到愤怒，从而导致了发帖。而且，你知道，我们知道这类事情会导致我们态度的改变。
We're not certain to the extent at which it can impact our actual behaviors. We know attitudes can influence behaviors, but we have to do more research to connect those dots and make sure that there's a clear path so that we better understand how fake news and false information, false information can impact. consumers. And I sort of feel like part of it is that there's just so much information out there, that it can be hard to decipher which is which, and what seems different to me about today is the way in which political figures are participating in this.
我们不确定它能在多大程度上影响我们的实际行为。我们知道态度可以影响行为，但我们需要做更多的研究来连接这些点，并确保有一条清晰的路径，以便我们更好地理解假新闻和虚假信息如何影响消费者。我感觉部分原因是现在的信息实在太多了，很难辨别哪是哪，而今天对我来说似乎不同的是政治人物参与其中的方式。
People that we're supposed to trust in leadership roles just don't seem to be discerning the information either. Well, you can't call everything fake news. because information doesn't necessarily align with your personal views that you have already doesn't mean that it's fake. We had a session this morning about fake news, and one thing that was brought up is just because something is your truth does not necessarily mean it's the truth. There's a difference there.
我们本应信任的担任领导角色的人似乎也无法辨别信息。嗯，你不能把所有东西都称为假新闻。因为信息不一定符合你已经持有的个人观点，并不意味着它是假的。我们今天早上有一个关于假新闻的会议，提到的一点是，仅仅因为某件事是你的真相，并不一定意味着它是事实。这之间是有区别的。
So just because people disagree with you doesn't mean that the information that they're presenting is fake, right, or false. It doesn't help that we are bombarded with all of this information all of the time. A lot of the information that's, you know, kind of determined to be fake news is spread through social media. Almost everyone has a social media account. That includes Facebook. It includes Twitter. It includes YouTube.
所以仅仅因为人们不同意你，并不意味着他们呈现的信息是假的，对吧，或者说是错误的。我们一直被所有这些信息轰炸，这无济于事。很多被认定为假新闻的信息都是通过社交媒体传播的。几乎每个人都有社交媒体账号。这包括Facebook。包括Twitter。包括YouTube。
So YouTube is still considered a social media platform. The information, you know, we see something on there. Most of the time, the information that we view already agrees with views we have. Because the information that is presented to us is based on our previous likes and clicks and all of that anyways. The algorithm that's working behind the scenes. That in itself is problematic because it does not present us with the whole picture on any topic. And if we only see one side of the story or whatever it is, all of the time we begin to believe that that is all of the information that we have. But we come across information. It makes us feel emotional. We get upset
所以YouTube仍然被认为是一个社交媒体平台。我们看到上面的信息，大多数时候，我们浏览的信息已经符合我们持有的观点。因为呈现给我们的信息无论如何都是基于我们之前的点赞、点击和所有这些行为。在幕后运作的算法。这本身就是有问题的，因为它没有向我们呈现任何话题的全貌。如果我们一直只看到故事的一面，或者无论是什么，我们就会开始相信这就是我们拥有的全部信息。但我们遇到了信息。它让我们感到情绪化。我们对此感到不安……
about it. We think other people should have this information. So we share it. We like it. We send it to all of our friends and family, and then the cycle just continues. We don't have the tools right now to decipher all of this information that's coming at us, and we live in a digital world where we want to know information right now. So if you have a question, you can pull out your phone, you can Google it, it gives you an answer, and you want the information right then. We don't really pause to look at the source of the information, where it came from, the credentials for the source, you know, we want our information immediately, and that's,
我们认为其他人也应该拥有这些信息。所以我们分享它。我们点赞。我们把它发给所有的朋友和家人，然后循环就继续了。我们现在没有工具来辨别所有这些向我们涌来的信息，我们生活在一个数字世界里，我们想立刻知道信息。所以如果你有一个问题，你可以拿出手机，你可以谷歌一下，它会给你一个答案，而你想要的就是那一刻的信息。我们并没有真正停下来去查看信息的来源、它来自哪里、来源的凭证，你知道，我们想要立即得到信息，而这……
that kind of feeds into the issue also. Right, and I've heard people refer to it sort of as like, it's not that people are bad or that they're even partisan, it's more like kind of like lazy thinking. Like we just don't go to the effort to actually figure out whether what we're looking at is true or not. And I thought what was interesting about this morning that was mentioned is that it's often individuals in the baby boomer generation, they're often retweeting or reliking these sorts fake news, it's not necessarily younger generations.
这也在某种程度上助长了这个问题。没错，我听过人们把它称为，就像，并不是人们变坏了，甚至不是他们有党派偏见，更像是某种懒惰的思考。就像我们只是不去努力去弄清楚我们看到的东西是否真实。我觉得今天早上提到的有趣的一点是，通常是婴儿潮一代，他们经常转发或重新点赞这些假新闻，并不一定是年轻一代。
And I come across that in my own family. I have older cousins where I see that they have liked something or shared it on their Facebook. And I can tell it's not true. I think you were telling a story earlier about something you saw on Facebook. Right. I was given an example of how social media has been used to share fake news or false misinformation.
我在我自己的家庭中也遇到过这种情况。我有年长的表亲，我看到他们点赞了某些东西或在他们的Facebook上分享了它。而我可以看出那不是真的。我想你之前讲过一个关于你在Facebook上看到的东西的故事。没错。我举了一个例子，说明社交媒体是如何被用来分享假新闻或虚假错误信息的。
So there was a post I came across a couple years ago and it was a picture of a wall. And it was maybe 2016, 2017. It was a picture of a wall and it said something to the effect that Mexico has the ability to protect its borders. Why can't we? So the intent was to compare this wall that is supposedly in Mexico separating it from, I believe, Guatemala to the proposed border wall that's been, you know, proposed to be built here between the United States and Mexico. So a couple of things. Yes, it's a picture of a wall, but it is not a picture of a wall in Mexico or Guatemala. It's not a wall that separates those two areas.
所以几年前我偶然看到一篇帖子，那是一张墙的照片。那可能是2016年、2017年。那是一张墙的照片，上面写着大意是墨西哥有能力保护其边界。为什么我们不能？所以其目的是将这堵据称在墨西哥将其与危地马拉隔开的墙，与提议在美国和墨西哥之间修建的边境墙进行比较。所以有几点。是的，这是一张墙的照片，但它不是墨西哥或危地马拉的墙的照片。它不是隔开那两个地区的墙。
Instead, it's a picture of a wall that is in Israel. It was built in 2013. It has nothing to do with our political issue whatsoever. But people saw it, they shared it, retreated it, and just it spread like wildfire. And you can see consumers, they believe it. They don't verify the source of the information. And they want everyone to, you know, they see this and they're like, see if Mexico can, Mexico can protect their borders, why can't we do the same, but that's not real.
相反，这是一张位于以色列的墙的照片。它建于2013年。它与我们的政治问题毫无关系。但人们看到了它，他们分享了它，转发了它，它就像野火一样蔓延开来。你可以看到消费者，他们相信它。他们不核实信息的来源。他们想让每个人都，你知道，他们看到这个，他们就像，看如果墨西哥能，墨西哥能保护他们的边界，为什么我们不能做同样的事情，但那不是真的。
That's fake news. That's false information. It's misinformation and it's misleading consumers. So that's another thing in terms of how we define fake news. What's the intent of the author that put it together? So if you tell me something, well, I heard blah, blah, blah, if that's really what you heard and you really believe it, you telling me does not necessarily mean you're sharing fake news. But the author, if the original author, if the original author,
那是假新闻。那是虚假信息。它是错误信息，并且在误导消费者。所以这是我们在定义假新闻方面的另一件事。作者将其放在一起的意图是什么？所以如果你告诉我某件事，嗯，我听到了某某某，如果那确实是你听到的，而且你真的相信它，你告诉我并不一定意味着你在分享假新闻。但作者，如果原始作者，如果原始作者……
author of that information knew it was false information intended to deceive, then that's different. So it's the intent behind it. We can't really blame everyone for sharing information that they come across on social media. We really need to look at where the information is originating from and the author's intent and creating it in the first place. Right, because it's the intent of the author that matters, not the reshare or the retweeter who might just be doing it because, like you said before, it evoked some sort of emotional reaction in them and they felt compelled to share it with others, or because, you know, it reaffirmed something they already believed in.
该信息的作者知道它是旨在欺骗的虚假信息，那就不一样了。所以这是背后的意图。我们不能真的责怪每个人分享他们在社交媒体上遇到的信息。我们真的需要看看信息是从哪里起源的，以及作者最初创作它的意图。没错，因为重要的是作者的意图，而不是转发者或转发的人，他们可能只是因为，就像你之前说的，它在他们心中引发了某种情绪反应，他们感到有义务与他人分享，或者因为，你知道，它重申了他们已经相信的东西。
Right. I think the other thing what we were talking about this morning was this idea of wanting to be right. Right. We all want to be right about everything, right? Yeah. Yeah. So it ends up becoming what we call in psychology a confirmation bias, right?
没错。我想我们今天早上谈论的另一件事是这种想要正确的感觉。没错。我们都想在每件事上都是对的，对吧？是的。是的。所以它最终变成了我们在心理学中所说的确认偏误，对吧？
Is that we seek out information that confirms the beliefs we already have, as opposed to seeking on information that might counter it. Right, and the algorithms on social media does not help that whatsoever. It makes it worse. So, I mean, we've hit on this a little bit, but like what are the consequences of, you know, all this sort of misinformation and the negative intent around it? Why do we care? Why should we care?
就是我们寻找证实我们已有信念的信息，而不是寻找可能反驳它的信息。没错，而社交媒体上的算法对此毫无帮助。它让情况变得更糟。所以，我的意思是，我们已经稍微触及了这一点，但像所有这些错误信息及其背后的负面意图有什么后果？我们为什么要关心？我们为什么要关心？
Why does it matter? If people start to believe false information, then they start to doubt accurate information that is accurate. So they start to dispute scientific evidence. You know, they start to fully believe this and misinformation. They start to kind of fall into numerous conspiracy theories and those types of things. And depending on the type of content that's in the fake news or misinformation that they're consuming, it can impact their attitudes. So the research I've conducted has specifically looked at outcomes related to immigration attitudes,
这有什么关系？如果人们开始相信虚假信息，那么他们就会开始怀疑准确的信息。所以他们开始质疑科学证据。你知道，他们开始完全相信这些错误信息。他们开始陷入各种阴谋论和这类事情中。并且根据他们消费的假新闻或错误信息中的内容类型，它会影响他们的态度。我进行的研究专门研究了与移民态度相关的结果……
immigration policy attitudes and Islamophobia. And what I found multiple times is that people who are exposed to negative images related to these particular, hot topics, controversial topics through fake news, tend to have, they develop more fake, more negative attitudes. So it amplifies negative attitudes that they might already have. What we don't know is how the amplification of those negative attitudes, how it impacts behaviors. As a researcher, I'm interested in, for instance, the recent mass shootings that took place.
移民政策态度和伊斯兰恐惧症。我多次发现，那些通过假新闻接触到与这些特定热门话题、争议话题相关的负面图像的人，往往会发展出更负面的态度。所以它放大了他们可能已经持有的负面态度。我们不知道的是，这种负面态度的放大如何影响行为。作为一名研究人员，我感兴趣的是，例如，最近发生的那些大规模枪击事件。
I'm interested in better understanding the social media profiles of those perpetrators. I want to know exactly what they were looking at in terms of social media. What were they looking at on Facebook? What were they looking at on YouTube? Obviously, they had negative attitudes. Something is off. Something is there. So we all have biases and we all have, you know, our personal opinions, but there's something different when people kind of take it to the next level and cause terror.
我有兴趣更好地了解那些肇事者的社交媒体资料。我想确切地知道他们在社交媒体方面在看什么。他们在Facebook上看了什么？他们在YouTube上看了什么？显然，他们有负面态度。有些地方不对劲。有些东西在那里。所以我们都有偏见，我们都有，你知道，我们的个人观点，但当人们把事情提升到下一个层次并制造恐怖时，情况就不同了。
Right. Or, you know, I thinking sometimes it can be politically slanted, but there are other ways that fake news has had consequences like around vaccines, right? And so, you know, you have these false stories around vaccines based off of false research in certain ways. But when you look at the real science, of course, it tells a different story. but at this point, you almost can't rewind the clock. Like once people start to believe something and they have lost trust in institutions, then what do we do? We need to better arm our consumers.
没错。或者，你知道，我想有时它可能是政治倾向性的，但假新闻产生后果还有其他方式，比如围绕疫苗，对吧？所以，你知道，你有这些基于某种程度上虚假研究的关于疫苗的虚假故事。但当你观察真正的科学时，当然，它讲述了一个不同的故事。但在这一点上，你几乎无法倒转时钟。就像一旦人们开始相信某件事，并且他们对机构失去了信任，那么我们该怎么办？我们需要更好地武装我们的消费者。
We need to make sure that they are better educated in terms of media literacy. We need to make sure that they understand that sometimes, not all the time, but sometimes authors who put out information are trying to trick them. We need to arm them so that they're aware of these facts,
我们需要确保他们在媒体素养方面受到更好的教育。我们需要确保他们理解，有时，不是一直，但有时发布信息的作者是在试图欺骗他们。我们需要武装他们，让他们意识到这些事实……
that it's not fake news. Fake news is not, you know, that they're aware of these facts and that they can better protect themselves. We need to make sure that consumers know how, because identifying information that's false is very hard. It's difficult. So we need to make sure that consumers know how to pause,
这不是假新闻。假新闻不是，你知道，他们意识到这些事实，并且他们可以更好地保护自己。我们需要确保消费者知道如何，因为识别虚假信息是非常困难的。这很困难。所以我们需要确保消费者知道如何停下来……
check the source of the information, where is it coming from? If they can't find the source, just leave it. Because if you're not able to verify the source, the source of the information, I would just consider it false information and not even go there. But consumers also need to kind of, especially in terms of social media, pause when they see something that makes them emotional, whether it's negative or positive emotion, pause for a minute, think about what is it about this piece of information that's got me upset? Why do I want to share it with other people and make sure that they understand that,
核实信息的来源，它来自哪里？如果他们找不到来源，就别管它。因为如果你无法核实来源，信息的来源，我只会认为它是虚假信息，甚至不去理会。但消费者也需要某种程度上，特别是在社交媒体方面，当他们看到让他们情绪化的东西时停下来，无论是负面还是正面情绪，停下来想一分钟，这则信息中有什么让我感到不安？为什么我想和别人分享它，并确保他们理解……
you know, if you share it, then to a certain extent, you're someone. somewhat responsible for spreading false information. So if we can better arm our consumers and help them to be better able to identify false information, I think it will help a little bit. But once that trust is gone, we have to work to get it back. And I think, like you said, it can be really challenging because the producers of the false information are using visuals and these provocative headlines and trying to go for shock, right?
你知道，如果你分享它，那么在某种程度上，你就是某人。在某种程度上要为传播虚假信息负责。所以如果我们能更好地武装我们的消费者，帮助他们更好地识别虚假信息，我认为这会有所帮助。但一旦那种信任消失了，我们就必须努力把它找回来。而且我认为，就像你说的，这可能真的很有挑战性，因为虚假信息的生产者正在使用视觉效果和这些挑衅性的标题，并试图追求冲击力，对吧？
So that it gets you worked up and it gets you reactionary instead of pausing. And that's exactly why false news or fake news is so memorable, why it's persistent. I mean, there's been research that has shown that even if you tell people, okay, the information that you just shared is false, here is proof that it's false. Here's a scientific study that proves the information you just told me is false. They still believe it. Because of how shocking it is, because of how sensational it is. It has more of an effect than real information.
这样它就会让你激动起来，让你产生反应，而不是停下来。而这正是假新闻如此令人难忘、如此持久的原因。我的意思是，已经有研究表明，即使你告诉人们，好吧，你刚刚分享的信息是假的，这是它虚假的证据。这是一项证明你刚才告诉我的信息是虚假的科学研究。他们仍然相信它。因为它太令人震惊了，因为它太耸人听闻了。它比真实信息有更大的影响。
So that in itself is part of the issue. People need to understand. If you see a headline that just seems completely out of this world, completely unrealistic, it probably is. The headlines should just be from more hard news or reputable news sources. They tend to just relay the facts. If you see something that is shocking, whether it's images, the headline itself, the way that the information is shared, then there's a reason for that, you know, that it makes it more memorable,
所以这本身就是问题的一部分。人们需要明白。如果你看到一个标题看起来完全不可思议，完全不现实，它可能就是这样。标题应该只是来自更硬核的新闻或信誉良好的新闻来源。他们倾向于只是转述事实。如果你看到一些令人震惊的东西，无论是图像、标题本身，还是分享信息的方式，那么这都是有原因的，你知道，这让它更令人难忘……
but it doesn't make it true. Right. You know, and I think, you know, in the wake of sort of this phenomenon, some social media companies have tried to take countermeasures, right? Sort of labeling things as false or putting tags on them. Seems like the research is pretty mixed on whether or not that's effective. Is that an accurate read? Well, for one, when YouTube did that, it totally messed up one of my research studies.
但这并不意味着它是真的。没错。你知道，而且我认为，你知道，在这种现象之后，一些社交媒体公司试图采取反制措施，对吧？比如将事物标记为虚假或给它们贴上标签。研究似乎对这是否有效非常矛盾。这是一个准确的解读吗？嗯，首先，当YouTube这样做时，它完全搞砸了我的一个研究项目。
So I'm not, you're not a fan. Well, I think we have to be aware of where the, who's that, who's to blame, right? Who's responsible for the information? So you have social media platforms that don't want to be responsible for the sharing of misinformation that could potentially lead to whatever negative consequences. And I think that's why they have started to step in and start to block content and remove stuff like the Alex Jones YouTube channel, which is I was using that as a fake news example and a research study. So I had to stop data collection altogether and kind of use what I already had. So we'll see how that goes.
所以我不，你不是粉丝。嗯，我认为我们必须意识到哪里，谁该受到指责，对吧？谁对信息负责？所以你有社交媒体平台，它们不想为传播可能导致任何负面后果的错误信息负责。我认为这就是为什么它们开始介入并开始屏蔽内容并删除像亚历克斯·琼斯的YouTube频道这样的东西，我当时在研究中使用它作为假新闻的例子。所以我不得不完全停止数据收集，并使用我已经拥有的东西。所以我们将看看情况如何。
But they did it because they don't want to be responsible for the information. But what we're looking at is not a technological problem. It is not a social media problem. It is a people problem. Our, you know, looking for information that already confirms what we believe, being drawn to information that is shocking, sensational, that causes us to be emotional, wanting to tell everyone information that we think we know. Those are areas that are problematic that are kind of increasing the spread of social media,
但他们这样做是因为他们不想为信息负责。但我们所看到的问题不是技术问题。这不是社交媒体问题。这是一个人的问题。我们的，你知道，寻找已经证实我们所相信的信息，被令人震惊、耸人听闻、导致我们情绪化的信息所吸引，想要告诉每个人我们认为我们知道的信息。这些领域是有问题的，它们在某种程度上增加了社交媒体的传播……
you know, the fake news through social media. So we have to be very cautious about taking stuff down. Who makes a decision to take? it down, you know, are they biased in some way? So is it their bias that is leading them to want to remove content or do they know for sure, have they done their fact-checking and they know for sure that it's false information? So it becomes kind of sticky because, you know, we have the right to free the free speech, but that doesn't mean we have the right for hate speech, for instance, or free speech without consequences. So there's a line and we have to as a society
你知道，通过社交媒体传播的假新闻。所以我们在删除东西时必须非常谨慎。谁来决定删除它，你知道，他们是否在某种程度上带有偏见？所以是他们的偏见导致他们想要删除内容，还是他们确定无疑，他们是否进行了事实核查，并且他们确定无疑它是虚假信息？所以这变得有点棘手，因为，你知道，我们有言论自由的权利，但这并不意味着我们有仇恨言论的权利，例如，或者没有后果的言论自由。所以有一条界线，我们作为一个社会必须……
kind of figure out exactly where that is and what's protected and what isn't. Do we have an administration that can do that? I think something like that has to be a bipartisan decision. That's an excellent bipartisan response. So both sides of the aisle have to come together to kind of help solve this issue. And one thing we have to do is quit calling everything fake news. Just because I tell you something is fake news, doesn't. mean that it's fake.
弄清楚那条界线到底在哪里，什么是受保护的，什么不是。我们有一个能做到这一点的政府吗？我认为这样的事情必须是一个两党共同的决定。这是一个极好的两党回应。所以两党都必须团结起来，帮助解决这个问题。我们需要做的一件事是停止把所有东西都称为假新闻。仅仅因为我告诉你某件事是假新闻，并不意味着它是假的。
Sure. You know, so we have to stop throwing that term around as if, I mean, we hear it every day. Right. We have to stop that and pay attention and make sure that what we're sharing is factual information, you know, regardless of who it is. And just stay off Twitter. She says after I've already tweeted out that I am here right now doing this podcast. You know, one of the things you brought up earlier that made me think was around Alex Jones,
当然。你知道，所以我们必须停止到处使用那个词，好像，我的意思是，我们每天都能听到它。没错。我们必须停止那样做，并注意确保我们分享的是事实信息，你知道，无论它是谁。而且只是远离Twitter。她在说出我已经发推文说我现在就在这里做这个播客之后。你知道，你之前提到的让我思考的一件事是关于亚历克斯·琼斯……
and his YouTube channel. And I think one of the other motives around spreading misinformation is for profit. So a lot of his, if you ever watch his work, is really around selling a lot of products that he has. And he gets people to click on his stuff
和他的YouTube频道。而且我认为传播错误信息的另一个动机是为了利润。所以他的很多，如果你看过他的作品，实际上都是围绕销售他拥有的很多产品。他让人们点击他的东西……
and come to his page because he's being sensationalist and loud. And at the end, he's really trying to sell you something. What role do you think that is, that sort of selling the product, component of sort of behind all of this spread, the intent of spreading? Well, we see the for-profit issue in hard news or mainstream news also.
并来到他的页面，因为他耸人听闻且大声喧哗。而最后，他实际上是在试图向你推销东西。你认为那种销售产品的成分在所有这些传播背后，传播的意图是什么？嗯，我们在硬新闻或主流新闻中也看到了营利问题。
Everything is for-profit, right? So even in mainstream traditional news outlets, they have commercials that they're trying to sell you in between news breaks. And the way they present information is done in such a way where they want you as a consumer to watch their show rather than the other one so that they can make more money. So it kind of boils down to profit regardless of if it's hard news or fake news. Fake news gets a little bit more tricky because for instance, yes, Alex Jones was selling products and that type of stuff, but not everyone who creates fake news is getting a profit in that way. It doesn't always have to be a monetary profit. It could be, well, I want a lot of people to vote this particular way, so I'm going to create a
一切都是为了利润，对吧？所以即使在主流传统新闻媒体中，他们也有商业广告，试图在新闻间隙向你推销。他们呈现信息的方式是这样的，他们希望你作为消费者观看他们的节目而不是别人的，这样他们才能赚更多的钱。所以无论它是硬新闻还是假新闻，它最终都归结为利润。假新闻变得有点棘手，因为例如，是的，亚历克斯·琼斯在销售产品和这类东西，但并不是每个制造假新闻的人都以那种方式获得利润。它不一定非要是金钱利润。它可以是，嗯，我希望很多人以这种特定的方式投票，所以我将创造一个……
some sensational information and put it out there to try to convince people to do what I want them to do. Right. To influence them in some way. In some way. It doesn't necessarily have to be a monetary issue. So, you know, for our listeners, other than being more media literate or media savvy, what can people do to help figure out what news is legitimate and what news might not be? Well, you can fact-check the news.
一些耸人听闻的信息并发布出来，试图说服人们做我想让他们做的事。没错。以某种方式影响他们。以某种方式。它不一定非要是金钱问题。所以，你知道，对于我们的听众，除了更具媒体素养或媒体精明之外，人们可以做些什么来帮助弄清楚哪些新闻是合法的，哪些新闻可能不是？嗯，你可以核实新闻。
That will be helpful. Well, let's say I don't have time to fact-check the news. Then you shouldn't be reading. Then don't read it. Because we have to be wise consumers. You know, we live in an age where we want everything. Right now, we want everything instant. We don't really want to, we don't have time to do that.
那会有帮助。嗯，假设我没有时间核实新闻。那你就不应该读。那就别读它。因为我们必须成为明智的消费者。你知道，我们生活在一个我们想要一切的时代。现在，我们想要一切即时的。我们真的不想，我们没有时间那样做。
We're all working. Everyone is busy. But we need to make the time. If we want accurate information, we have to work to get it. And one of the best things about social media and the internet is that we have all of the information we could possibly think of at our fingertips. But it's how we're using those tools that starts to become problematic because people are creating information that's not real, it's fake, it's false. And the more you spread it, the more people start to believe it. So we need to make sure that we're checking the source.
我们都在工作。每个人都很忙。但我们需要挤出时间。如果我们想要准确的信息，我们必须努力去获取它。社交媒体和互联网最好的事情之一就是我们触手可及地拥有我们能想到的所有信息。但我们如何使用这些工具开始变得有问题，因为人们正在创造不真实、虚假、错误的信息。你传播得越多，人们就开始越相信它。所以我们需要确保我们正在核实来源。
and we have to engage in some type of self-reflection. Why is this information important to me? How does it make me feel? Why do I want to share it? And we need to pause and really kind of consider those things before we share information we come across on social media, before we tell our friends and family. Why is it important to us?
而且我们必须进行某种自我反思。为什么这些信息对我重要？它让我有什么感觉？为什么我想分享它？我们需要停下来，在分享我们在社交媒体上遇到的信息之前，在告诉我们的朋友和家人之前，真正考虑这些事情。为什么它对我们很重要？
I also thought it was interesting this morning talking about how we only maybe receive half of the story. And so what that made me think about is, can we be more inquisitive? right as individuals. Can we ask yourselves, okay, I've heard this part of the story, is there more? What's the and? There's always more. Right. There's always more. And we do get half the story. So even from like mainstream news sources, CNN and Fox, those are both of those avenues are very biased. So on the way here,
我也觉得今天早上谈论我们可能只收到了一半的故事很有趣。所以这让我想到的是，我们可以更好奇吗？作为个人。我们可以问自己，好吧，我已经听到了故事的这一部分，还有更多吗？什么是“和”？总有更多。没错。总有更多。而且我们确实只得到了故事的一半。所以即使是来自主流新闻来源，CNN和福克斯，这两个渠道都非常偏颇。所以在来这里的路上……
I was kind of flipping back and forth between how Fox News and how CNN was discussing the mass shootings that recently took place and the president's tweets and rhetoric and those types of things that have happened prior to and shortly after. And both of those sources are presenting the same story. Right. Right. So both of them have facts in there. But the way they're describing it, the slant they're put on it, the spin, all of that is very biased.
我一直在来回切换，看福克斯新闻和CNN是如何讨论最近发生的大规模枪击事件，以及总统的推文和言论，以及那些在之前和之后不久发生的事情。这两个来源都在呈现同一个故事。没错。没错。所以它们都有事实在里面。但他们描述它的方式，他们放在上面的倾向，旋转，所有这些都非常偏颇。
So if you're only watching, say, CNN, you only get half the story. Or if you're only watching Fox, you're only getting half the story. We need to make sure that we're getting our information from multiple sources, engaging in fact-checking, doing our own research. No one wants to do it, but you have to do it if you're going to be a responsible consumer. At some point, it's our responsibility to make sure that what we believe as truth for ourselves is actually the truth. Right, right. Is there a reason to feel hopeful?
所以如果你只看，比如，CNN，你只得到了故事的一半。或者如果你只看福克斯，你只得到了故事的一半。我们需要确保我们从多个来源获取信息，进行事实核查，做我们自己的研究。没有人想做，但如果你要成为一个负责任的消费者，你就必须做。在某种程度上，确保我们为自己相信的真相实际上是真相，是我们的责任。没错，没错。有理由感到希望吗？
there's always reasons to be hopeful because we can always make a change. That's one of the things that's great about being people is if you see something that you don't like the way things are going, then you can put an effort and energy to make a change. And we have as a society, we have to all come together and decide that that's something that we want to do. If we don't, then we're just going to see this type of thing
总是有理由感到希望，因为我们总是可以做出改变。这是作为人的一件伟大的事情，如果你看到你不喜欢事情发展的方式，那么你可以投入努力和精力去做出改变。我们作为一个社会，我们必须团结起来，决定这是我们想要做的事情。如果我们不这样做，那么我们只会看到这类事情……
just progress and probably snowballing and just continuously get worse. But if as a society we come together and say, okay, we want to make sure that the information that we are getting is accurate, true information, then we can make sure that that happens. So it's on us? On consumers.
只是发展并可能像滚雪球一样，只会持续变得更糟。但如果我们作为一个社会团结起来说，好吧，我们想要确保我们获得的信息是准确的、真实的信息，那么我们就可以确保这种情况发生。所以这取决于我们？取决于消费者。
And probably some people in charge. Hopefully. If we're passing laws and that type of thing, it really has to be something that's bipartisan. They have to be able to put their political differences aside and figure out a way to work together. Like, you could be Democrat, I could be Republican, that's fine. You have to be able to put your differences aside and work together to benefit society as a whole. Right.
可能还有一些负责人。希望如此。如果我们正在通过法律和这类事情，它真的必须是两党共同的事情。他们必须能够把他们的政治分歧放在一边，想出一种合作的方式。比如，你可以是民主党人，我可以是共和党人，那没关系。你必须能够把你的分歧放在一边，共同努力造福整个社会。没错。
And I think, you know, as we had talked, society benefits from facts. Yes, factual information is helpful. So that then you can make informed decisions about what you do. Exactly. Yeah. Well, thank you so much for being here today. Thank you for having me. I really want to thank Dr. Wright for sharing your expertise on this really timely and important topic.
而且我认为，你知道，正如我们所谈到的，社会受益于事实。是的，事实信息是有帮助的。这样你就可以对你所做的事情做出明智的决定。没错。是的。好吧，非常感谢您今天来到这里。谢谢邀请。我真的要感谢赖特博士在这个非常及时和重要的话题上分享您的专业知识。
If you liked what you heard today, you can always email us with your ideas and thoughts at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. If you're interested in hearing more of our podcasts, you can get them on iTunes, on Stitcher, wherever you get your podcasts. They're also available on our website, www. speakingof psychology.org. I'm Dr. Vale Wright. It's really been a pleasure to guest to... host this podcast. I want to thank all our listeners and everybody take care. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你喜欢今天听到的内容，你可以随时通过Speaking of Psychology at APA.org给我们发送电子邮件，提出你的想法和意见。如果你有兴趣收听我们更多的播客，你可以在iTunes、Stitcher上获取它们，或者在你获取播客的任何地方。它们也可以在我们的网站www.speakingofpsychology.org上找到。我是瓦尔·赖特博士。能客串主持这个播客真是太荣幸了。我要感谢我们所有的听众，大家保重。本期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。